-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Well, guys, let's get into it.
Last night was the
94th Annual Academy Awards.
[ Cheers and applause,
laughter ]
America may be divided,
but it was kind of nice
for all of us to come together
and say "holy crap"
at the same time.
Of course, I have to address
the big moment
that everyone's talking about,
and that is
Questlove winning
the Oscar for Best Documentary!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes! Yes!
Questlove!
The best.
Quest told me he's not gonna
let it go to his head.
Well, actually, his
assistant's assistant told me
I couldn't get in touch
with Questlove,
but he is going to be
on the show tonight.
He's gonna be our guest
on the show, and we'll talk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tonight. Bringing the Oscar.
But, actually, something else
did happen on the show.
Do you guys remember a few years
ago when the Oscars
literally announced the wrong
winner for Best Picture?
It turns out that was
child's play.
That meant -- No.
Yeah, there was a pretty rough
moment during the show,
and I think you all know what
I'm talking about.
Everyone in the audience
looked shocked,
and for once,
it wasn't from the Botox.
Seriously, you know it was
a strange awards show
when it ends with a statement
from the LAPD.
You know what I'm saying?
Yep, in just a split second,
the Oscars went from
Oscar de la Renta to
Oscar de la Hoya, you know?
Look, you move the award for
Best Film Editing
out of the main broadcast,
and all hell breaks lose.
I've been saying this...
But let's focus on the positive.
I thought Amy Schumer,
Regina Hall, and Wanda Sykes
did a great job
hosting the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They did so well,
they are already rehearsing
their nos for when they are
asked to come back.
Yeah, it's great.
It's a tough job
hosting the Oscars.
It's a lot like drinking
Hard Mountain Dew.
At first,
you can't wait to try it,
and then, after, you're like,
"Never again."
You know?
But on the bright side,
the Oscars rebounded from
last year's record-low ratings,
drawing over 15 million viewers.
That is like taking all
the people who watched
the Best Picture nominees
and adding 15 million viewers.
There were a lot of reasons
more people watched this year,
and I think one of them
might have been
Timothée Chalamet outfit.
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Yep, it turns out Chalamet
is French for "chest wax."
-Oh.
-Yeah.
Vladimir Putin calls that look
"business casual."
But let's switch gears.
During a speech in Poland
this weekend,
President Biden went off script
and said that Putin
cannot remain in power.
However, The White House
quickly walked it back
and said Biden wasn't
calling for his removal.
That's like if
Reagan's staff said,
"He actually meant to say,
'Mr. Gorbachev,
tear down this wallpaper.'"
Meanwhile, I heard that,
this week,
the House is expected to pass
a bill legalizing marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This bill probably
won't pass right away.
Experts are saying that
they will most likely
puff, puff, then pass.
[ Laughter ]
That one guy really got it.
-Nice!
-One guy really got it.
-Yeah, really got it.
-He almost got it too soon.
He was like, "Ah-ha-ha!"
That's right -- the bill will be
signed at The White House,
then framed at White Castle.
That's interesting.
And, finally,
a woman in the U.K.
just broke the world record
for the most
chicken nuggets
eaten in one minute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she did it after
telling her boyfriend,
"I don't want my own.
I'll just eat a few of yours."
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It is Monday.
We are excited to be back.
We have a great, great
week of shows ahead.
Jared Leto will be here.
Sienna Miller will be here.
Hugh Jackman will be joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we have --
I know -- we love Hugh Jackman.
And we have a music performance
from Red Hot Chili Peppers.
This is a big week.
-Whoa!
-But, first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
He is the host of "Last Week
Tonight with John Oliver,"
which airs Sundays at
11:00 p.m. on HBO.
John Oliver is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Super-funny.
Plus, she's one of
our favorites.
She stars in
the new film "Moonshot,"
which begins streaming
this Thursday on HBO Max.
Lana Condor is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, he just won an
Academy Award last night
for his documentary,
"Summer of Soul."
We're talking to
Questlove from The Roots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got music from
Buddy featuring Blxst tonight.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I loved the Academy Awards
last night.
I mean, despite that incident.
I loved seeing awards shows.
It makes me happy.
My mom would be really
into award shows,
any award show -- Emmys, Oscars.
My mom would dress up in a
dress, like, in a gown kind of.
-Aww.
-Yeah. And we'd have champagne,
if it was, like, cheap
champagne, whatever it was.
She would, like,
have a speech ready to go.
Like, we loved watching it.
And that's -- It was like,
"Oh, they have hosts again."
It was so -- a step back
to normalcy, you know?
And I loved the opening
with Beyoncé
and just Beyoncé looking
awesome, as always,
and that smile
like she can only do.
Like, she just --
She knows how to do it.
And then I thought the hosts
did a great job.
And then the Will-Chris thing,
I was just bummed, disturbed.
I wish it didn't happen.
But it didn't stop me
from just loving the business
and what we do.
We chose to do this, you know?
And to get to see everybody
and people that are on our show
and give out, you know, like,
editing, cinematography --
anything.
Just looking at
and celebrating this business.
I thought it was awesome,
and no way could you even
think that your friend
was going to be up for
an Academy Award and win.
And Questlove --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was screaming!
-Yeah.
-I was crying.
I was like, "Ahhh!"
I'm, like, texting him,
"Oh, my God!"
You know? Like...
Of course, he wasn't going to
deal with a text from me,
but I was just freaking out,
just so happy for him.
This guy worked
so hard on this thing,
and just -- It's an Oscars
that I'll never forget.
It was awesome.
So, congrats again to Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And everyone behind the Oscars.
It was a good show.